foreign
wanting to be with somebody else his
birthday so at the at the beginning of
this month two weeks after your
miscarriage yeah and I think because I
wasn't vocal to him about no no it's
because he's an ass
[Music]
what is going on this is John with a Dr
John deloney show
show about mental health and
relationships and marriage whatever you
got going on
I'm John and we I'm here to walk with
you
we got a whole gang back there they
don't do a lot I'm just kidding they do
everything and I stare off into space
and what y'all don't know is that Kelly
actually tells me all the answers to all
of your questions in my earpiece because
she's an oracle you were ruining the
wizard behind the thing you know behind
the curtain thing yes but I think Oracle
is Latin for just mean it doesn't say a
lot
I think that's what Oracle means so hey
um if you want to be on the show give me
a buzz at
1-844-693-3291 or go to John deloney.com
ask ask
please please please please let send
these episodes to everybody you know
send them everywhere and don't forget to
hit the Subscribe button
um let's go out to Kalamazoo which
sounds like a place in a Dr Seuss book
and talk to Hannah what's up Hannah hi
how are you today I'm good how's
Kalamazoo it's a party it is it's
beautiful today we got good weather
finally that's outstanding outstanding
Winter's finally over hey so what's up
hey uh yeah so I'll just give you a
little background before I jump into my
question here
um I'm 29 years old I'm married I have
one child
um and I've kind of always struggled
with making friends I can talk to anyone
but when it comes to connecting on a
deeper level it's very difficult for me
um I kind of always thought it was my
personalities but after talking with my
sisters it seems like we kind of all
have uh the struggle in one way or
another so my question is could my very
religious hyper-critical Baptist
preacher's kids are upbringing play a
role in why I struggle and really no not
at all you know listen this is a hundred
percent your fault in your personality
just fix you and all this goes away
right so yeah uh wait say that again you
said it perfectly that's the best I've
ever heard it okay hyper-religious hyper
religious uh or sorry religious
hyper-critical Baptist preacher kid over
here in Kalamazoo yes all of that yes
congratulations you are a therapist's
dream because you're going to be a
long-term client right
right and every stage along the way
um your parents have friends
no yeah probably not
um
were you a living figurine for them to
show the world
yes I was
like were you put in a bunch of awkward
situations with adults and
told that your job was to make sure they
a were comfortable and B that they could
see how great you were
uh yeah yes like like singing in prisons
lots of random things like that mm-hmm
ta-da
you are now a dysfunctional adult
congratulations yeah it popped up in
weird places it does tell me tell me uh
tell me about where it pops up
um so I have gotten older I've just kind
of know
small
um just just don't even feel the need to
connect with people on a deeper level
it's just all very shallow and
compartmentalized like I have one friend
for this I have one friend for this I
want her for something different you
know why you do that right
I do not
because you can't risk somebody actually
fully knowing you
yeah if they do there's this underlying
it and I'll even go as far to say oh by
the way I don't know if I talk about
this much on the show but halfway
through my life my dad quit being a
homicide detective and became a minister
at a large church so this is same team
discussion here okay
um if somebody truly knows you
the U doesn't have to be bad
it just has to be something they
disagree with
and then your parents
porcelain facade gets gets a mark on it
and that is so wired into every bit of
you and by the way the mark
is not just somebody at your church not
liking you it is eternal damnation and
burning in hell right I mean the stakes
are so insane
and so the risk is I I can't be fully
known
because if I'm fully known and I'm not
fully loved
I am Ash
and so you you I'm gonna challenge you
you said I I don't feel the need to
connect I disagree I think you
absolutely do
but you parse it out you Outsource it to
a bunch of different places
um to try to just get enough gulps of
oxygen to get through your day
yeah and that wears out
right yeah
how long have you
um tried to use your husband as an
oxygen tank
[Music]
been together four years yeah he's like
he's my person yeah
he is more than your person he's
probably your
heroin syringe too right
yeah
not that I know anything about what I'm
talking about from personally
um
yikes ma'am
so
how can I help because there's a lot
here right what what made you pick up
the phone and call
just I think I've never heard anyone
talk about this because I I've been
listening to a show for a while
um I hadn't I've been waiting for
someone to call in with this question
because I can't be the only one and
obviously I'm not
um so I I guess
it gets kind of weird uh where to start
I don't know if that's finding someone
that is truly safe like speaking out
that one person or let's back up let's
back out of that out of there then
because we're not at relationship yet
here's here's a couple things I want you
to
um
that you're gonna need to make peace
with okay okay you did good things
through your entire childhood and
probably through your adult life
so that
other people would see you and think
good about you and think good about the
name of the family and think good about
your parents
that does not mean that the good you did
was of no value
and that doesn't mean that you're a bad
evil person
okay the relationships you had served a
purpose
they were currency for your family their
currency for you and you know fair you
know better than most
how to make other people feel good
because that's been your job
and that can be by performing that can
be by getting straight A's that can be
by looking pretty but not too pretty
right you know how to do all that stuff
and it is freaking exhausting
and that doesn't mean that the
relationships that you had Were Somehow
less than or false or fake
they were what you knew
and what killed me was how long I
discounted all the good I did Growing Up
because I was doing it for the wrong
reasons but I was a kid I didn't know
and so I've been able to over the last
15 or 20 years turn that around with
some help from a counselor by the way
and begin to see I got a lot of practice
in doing good
and that is that has been a great gift
to me as I've been older because it's
just wired in
and now I've learned to do it for the
right reasons not because I'm trying to
perform because it really is kind of who
I am now
so I don't want you to Discount who you
are and the things you've done and where
you've been and where you've come from
because there's so much good there
there's a lot of growth too
but there's a lot of good there that is
that is in you at the cellular level so
you're not broken and not dysfunctional
you're not crazy
is that does that ring true yes yeah no
yeah that's great to hear okay yeah
because sometimes it can feel fake oh it
feels disgusting and fake yes
but also I've got buddies growing up
that went and got super high and beat up
everybody in trashed places and that was
fake too
that was there would be imposers too the
same as I was being a poser is Johnny
Jesus Freak
that was around drugs all the time I
shouldn't do them right see what I'm
saying like it's all all kids are trying
to figure out who they are and what they
are and they're practicing things and
they're practicing identities that's
that's a whole part of being a kid
and then I think there's a stunted
adolescence for
um
kids who grew up in the spotlight
whether it's a tiny Spotlight like a
local church or it's a spotlight of you
know kids of famous people there's this
weird thing where
you know that there's like you know you
can listen really quietly in your home
and know that so-and-so's cheating on
so-and-so and this greeter at your
church is really an awful person so you
have to grow up really fast
but your ability to experience freedom
and responsibility for your own
decisions is so restricted for so long
so you see a lot but you don't get to
experience a lot and that makes for a
weird 25 year old right
and there's this weird balance where
um
I want to be sexual with my husband and
I want to be Reckless but it also feels
weird because there's all this
background nonsense and then also I kind
of want to do this but this all of it's
just this weird and moving and so the
antidote for all of that
is you to really begin mining
m-i-n-i-n-g like going
on an adventure to find out who Hannah
is
and what she loves what she doesn't
believe anymore
what she wants for her and her family
and that is best expressed in
relationships
and that's hard
I just threw a lot at you speak back to
me
you're overwhelming I I I do think I've
done quite a bit of work here in my late
20s to see exactly who I am I I kind of
left the church and kind of rebalanced
everything to see okay what's mine and
what was my parents
um yeah and that's kind of where I'm at
right now I'm still not in a church or
anything but I do think I'm trying to
rebalance exactly who I am but the
friend thing is not is not falling into
place for me okay tell me if this rings
a bell
often ministers kids grow up with this
idea that every decision is the Super
Bowl
and if I get this wrong date wrong this
one date wrong
or if I have this sip of this drink or
I'm with a group of people and Janet
pulls out a cigarette right all like
everything is Do or Die
mm-hmm
kids can not carry that weight
and in the same way that my buddies who
are college athletic trainers are sure
are telling me that kids 18 and 19 year
olds are showing up to the university
with overuse joint injuries similar to
the elderly people
so they've got 18 and 19 year olds with
90 year old shoulders and 85 year old
knees and hips because of the insanity
of childhood Sports
you turn into a 21 25 28 29 year old
adult
who is so exhausted from carrying the
weight of every decision is the end of
time
and so the word I want you to tattoo on
your soul is practice
you've never fully sat down with one
friend and told them everything
you're just gonna practice that
and you're going to practice feeling so
exposed and so raw and so terrified on
your way home and you're replaying and I
know you do this because I do too you
replay every sentence did I say that
right are they gonna think this I should
probably call them oh I said that one
thing about that other person you do
that right yeah oh absolutely yes
because saying the wrong thing would
have ruined everything
and now
I want you to own I don't believe that
at all anymore
I didn't do X for this long and I don't
even believe that anymore and here's why
that's ownership
and that's you just got to practice it
practice saying no
practicing I don't believe that anymore
practicing practice
not answering a question because
answering questions got you gold stars
growing up practice just not practice
just not answering just
I don't know what do you think and
everything in your body will be like
answer answer just practice not yeah I
don't feel so awkward and weird
and then what you're gonna find is you
have value Beyond being able to give the
right verse in the right context
you're going to find that you have value
not performing
these lessons that you learned but
you're going to suddenly find that those
lessons are a part of you in a really
deep and profound way
and ultimately every single relationship
is a risk
and so you're gonna practice taking that
risk
I want to tell you one thing one one
heavy thing before I let you go okay
okay
your husband can't carry the weight of
all of this too
and so you've been married four or five
years right
uh two two years okay y'all been
together four years you've been married
to so I'm 18 years down the road
and I've almost wrecked our train
several times
by overloading the tracks
that means he can't be a trash compactor
for all of it
means you're gonna have to find whether
it's a counselor whether it's some
friends at a local church and and slowly
peek your head back in whether that's a
group of women that you invite over and
just say
I've never had friends before so I'm
going for it
everyone's gonna be weird and there'll
be two out of the six that stick around
you have to just practice that
okay
I can do that do you promise you won't
now hit the pendulum all the other way
and just hold a bunch of Secrets from
him and then not tell anybody and then
implode the whole thing
I didn't even think about that yep
because that's what I do that's what I
do I just toggle from everything or
nothing and neither of those things are
helpful they're not healthy
and I don't know if this helps or if
this makes you feel bad
over the last 30 years I've had entire
chunks of my life where I needed to walk
away for a minute
from corporate Church stuff
and in a way recalibrate
and sometimes that was with two or three
people that I really really trusted
sometimes that was with me
um in one person
that had some wisdom sometimes that was
me spending some time reading and
reflecting and writing
um
but when you grow up in that Spotlight
sometimes the the heat lamp gets really
hot
so I want you to know that you're not
broken you're not there's nothing wrong
with you
in fact taking some space I think can be
incredibly healthy and everybody's gonna
have an opinion about why you're doing
and what you're doing
keep yourself grounded with people that
you trust okay
okay cool
sounds good sounds like a good plan will
you practice this and then holler back
girl at me you're supposed to say on
your holler back girl but I'd love to
find out what happens when you
reach out to a few women and just tell
them everything
okay
head around doing that but yes I know it
feels insane it feels insane
it does go be quick go hey go be crazy
enjoy it have fun
and trust me you're gonna get burned
trust me it's gonna go awkward and weird
and then trust me you're gonna find one
or two people that say the magic words I
thought I was the only one
and that will be the soil of a new
relationship new friendship a person
that will walk with you will hold your
arms up in the desert
person will be a living embodiment of a
different way to do relationships and
Grace and
risk and man it's incredible it's
incredible when you find it thank you so
much for the call we'll be right back
[Music]
this show is sponsored by better help
folks take a minute to think about how
much time you spend on yourself it's
easy to get caught up in what people
need from you and want from you and
never think about what you need and then
you end up too stretched out burned out
all of the madness of our current world
resting on your shoulders
look sometimes I put my head down to
work and then realize I haven't had a
meaningful conversation with my wife and
kids all day I get focused on what I'm
doing and I'm running and running and
running
and I don't know how to come back
and therapy is a great way to learn new
skills that make you the best version of
yourself they help you set boundaries
and still have energy left to help
others without leaving yourself behind
so if you're thinking of starting
therapy give better help a try it's
totally online to fit into your schedule
you just fill out a brief questionnaire
to get matched with a licensed therapist
and you can switch therapists at any
time for no additional charge so find
more balance find Wellness with better
help visit betterhelp.com deloney today
to get 10 off your first month that's
better help
h-e-l-p.com slash deloni
all right we're back let's go to the
City of Angels and talk to Selena hola
Selena how are we doing
hi I'm doing good how are you so good
things going okay
yeah
at the roller coaster
yeah that's all yes I agree so what's up
how can I help
okay
um so so unfortunately
um on April 24th I went to the ER
um just to find out I have an ectopic
pregnancy oh gosh I'm sorry
yeah so um that was very traumatic in
itself but
um
what made it worse for me really was
well first off I didn't have the surgery
I don't know if you know too much about
that I do my in fact my wife had ectopic
pregnancy that ruptured and it was a it
was very very near-miss so yeah no I've
been down that road
um
so um thankfully I my tube wasn't
ruptured so I was able to get the shot
um and that was super painful in itself
but can we stop right there
yeah
can you take a huge deep breath for me
and hold it
hold it for one
two
three exhale
how far how far along were you
um so so I was only three weeks so
you're not allowed to say the word only
on the show when it comes to pregnancy
okay
can I ask you can I ask you a deeply
personal question
yeah what name did you have in your mind
um well I have a few names but if it's a
boy it's going to be Alexander after his
dad and then if it was a girl Arabella
well what was he or she because you know
you didn't it
lame so it had to be with an a
awesome awesome
um so for whatever it's worth
and um
I've had the honor and the Heartbreak of
sitting with countless women who've sat
with in in just dealing with pregnancy
loss
um I picked one
and I've got the names of all of the
miscarriages my wife and I have been
through she obviously she carries a line
share of it I've got a tattooed on my
body
having some sort of marker or moment for
the loss is really important okay
okay and I I don't think that's what the
call is about but I just want to put
that out there for you when people start
using words like only and this and
I want you just to take a second and
and and put a put a marker on the ground
okay
one in my life has been kind of
dismissive about this
so
um my mom she's not very like loving
so she was very like okay well it
happened let's get over it and then my
husband
he just constantly is working so he was
like yes it sucks but let's move on with
our lives and I'm the kind of person who
I'm like okay well I just want to wallow
in this for a minute
yeah
so you get to wallow and your mom was
was not loving before this right
correct yeah yeah she was a pageant mom
me and so you're a pageant gal huh
uh yeah so it was pageants then it
turned into Girl Scouts and then when I
went through my golf phase it was just
I love a good goth phase man
um
oh man what a mess okay so what's your
question how can I help
um so
Jen really is how how do I
how do I mainly for my husband explain
to him that this wasn't just a medical
mishap that happened with me this is
something that I'm mourning like a loss
of a child how is he responding
is he pretending this didn't happen is
he being an idiot like like
is he saying dumb like tell me what
what's going on with him
oh well first off he's a tanker driver
who works night shifts so he needs to
sleep during the day and that's very
important because it's dangerous but his
way of coping with things is I'm just
going to work and
um provide for my family and yes it
sucks but it happens let's move on those
were his exact words
yeah so I mean he's perfect in every way
except for he's very like he is not
right yes that's silly and that's the
dumbest thing you've said on this whole
call I know he's not perfect in every
way
um
so I'm heartbroken for a couple of
reasons one because I said something
very similar
he's a he's a tanker driver I was a nerd
so I didn't say not a big deal but I did
try to explain it away as though it
wasn't a big deal
and there's no excuse other than to say
I didn't know
I didn't understand I didn't know the
depths
and very similar like your husband I
knew one thing
when there was chaos and I knew my wife
was hurting but I didn't understand why
I didn't understand how
I did know I could help out around the
house by making more money so I just
went to work
and in a really backward strange way
um
it sounds like he's trying to tell you
he loves you
yeah
oh and I know that I know he does and um
we I'm I'm that type of person where I
will just like be so upset and let it
factor and to the point where it
explodes yeah and he can read that from
a mile away he knows the minute I'm
upset and he tries to talk it out and
uh yeah I know it's just I need to work
on that well it's less that and it's
more
after our second miscarriage when my
wife said the words I'm tired of my body
killing babies
that's when I finally got the extent of
her pain
I didn't understand
and it's not an excuse other than to say
I didn't know and I didn't even know to
ask
and yet that level of clarity and
insight
while hard for me to hear gave me a
whole new entryway so if I could do it
all over again I would have talked
infinitely less
now to listened more and I would have
asked questions that invited that level
of honesty
and also
I've forgiven myself and I've committed
to doing better and I've moved on
so I tell you to tell to tell to do this
I wouldn't say it's a thing to work on
but you've never experienced this before
Fair
hey
this is our first time and you had a mom
that trained you to take your feelings
and wad them up in a ball and flush them
on a toilet so that you could be a
porcelain human making your way through
the world right
yes you're a display item for her so you
don't have a model of what's sitting in
grief looks like and that's okay
grief will drag you underwater whether
you whether you have a model for it or
not right and so
there's something profound and Powerful
about telling your husband hey we need
to have a hard conversation
and maybe you write it down
but give giving him the truth about how
you feel
and how hard this loss is and being very
specific about how hard it is
how specific
I didn't understand that women when they
experience miscarriage they
feel betrayed by their own bodies
and they even the most powerful High
performing business women
have questions about self-worth I didn't
know any of that stuff
I worked I worked in Toronto right and I
didn't know
I didn't know that it can be so annoying
that you begin to question everything
about everything I didn't know
I didn't know about names
right so all that to say is
invite him into that conversation
now can I ask you a hard question
yeah
what is it about him that makes it you
not feel safe to have that conversation
because you've avoided it for some
reason I can tell you I was not a safe
place for my wife I wasn't
yeah why isn't he safe
um
but we've been together going on 10
years
so
um in our early years we were ravers and
you were what ravers
yeah so we used to go out partying every
weekend
yes and
um we just doing bad decisions and oh my
gosh Alina just say it what are you
you're like like
um
[Music]
I know uh yeah so I there's just been
situations where I feel like I'm on
walking on eggshells with him because I
feel like the rug's gonna get pulled out
for me at any minute so there's been
times where
um either he's being a little too
flirtatious with girls not so much
anymore but
um either that or we when we were
younger I did let him have a threesome
twice so
you let him have one or you participated
with him you said that funny
yeah I mean he he wanted it and I was 22
and I said sure okay so what does that
have to do with right now
I always feel this insecurity that I
can't just
be open
because I feel like the rug's gonna get
pulled out for me what does that mean
what does a rug get pulled out mean
[Applause]
he's going to either leave
or
um
something's gonna happen where we end up
divorced basically why do you think
that's happening
I I don't know I think it's just our
younger years when we were younger and
just the way that when alcohol gets in
the way of feelings and then there was
yelling matches and then the
whole him asking to be with other women
it's just made it made me very jaded
of course that would make anybody jaded
but you picked up the phone and called
me recently why
it's just I don't know I
could talk with my husband it's
I want to be open with him all the time
but I find it very hard because I feel
like if I say one thing wrong
that
um
it could result in Us ending and I don't
think has he said that Selena no he has
not so are you imagining this
I I think so
let me let me just tell you this
Secrets will kill you
and so if you hedge a relationship and
you hold the stuff that is important to
you like grief and loss and
I don't want to have sex with you and
another woman
if you need other women fine I am out of
this relationship
but the more you cash in
your own
being your own soul your own
authenticity
as some sort of hedge against him
leaving he is married to somebody he
knows he feels it in his bones
that is not being full with fully honest
with him
which is the best driver to send
somebody out
yeah and he's going to use you as the
excuse even though there's not one
you see how this just creates a
self-perpetuating cycle
yeah
when's the last time he mentioned
wanting to be with somebody else
um
at the beginning of this month
two weeks after your miscarriage
yeah
oh Selena lead with that good God
yeah and I think because I wasn't vocal
to him about no no it's because he's an
ass
ah I'm trying not to swear with all my
guts
yeah that level of insensitivity is
disgusting it's embarrassing
yeah
um stop just sit in that for a second
yeah he doesn't deserve to be with you
Selena
people do goofy things when they're 22.
people do unhealthy things in their 22.
people will do all whatever
you're gonna have to open hand some of
those choices y'all made when you're
going to raise and stuff can't let that
stuff just be a part of your past we all
have them
but you're also going to have to sit in
the fact that after
a really traumatic experience that you
didn't even have the words to discuss
his response was you know it's birthday
time
yeah
yeah exactly
exactly your pain and your hurt are
Justified okay
I'm disgusted with you
do you need to take a break
from him
from him no
no because
it's it's he'll say things like that and
I know he's not thinking of what I'm
feeling in the moment that's the problem
yeah
he's your husband
the vast majority of his thoughts in his
day should be focused on what his wife
is thinking and feeling
with the hope that the vast majority of
your thoughts are about how you can help
meet his needs what he's thinking what
he's experiencing
yeah
yeah and that is me as a human and very
much the caregiver of everyone
so
here's what I'm watching here's what I
want you to do okay
you've been protecting him for so long
you and I can't unwind this in a phone
call
what I can tell you is you need to talk
to somebody very very quickly okay
because you've got a you need to sit
down with a professional counselor
a to talk about how to grieve
because you're gonna have to grieve the
distance between you and your mom that
should not have been there but was
you're gonna have to grieve the fact
that your mom used you as a as a
figurine for her own
um
her own
self uh
she propped herself up using you
yes
and
and now in the moments when you need
your husband the most he's like hey
very similarly
I want to use you too for my birthday
and all that's a lot and only the only
response you've got in your soul
is to look at the mirror and blame
yourself and try to fix it
and you didn't do anything wrong with
your mom
that was on her
and I'll tell you this even the most
sexually adventurous people I know
would never
in a million years
13 or 14 days removed from such tragedy
be like hey you know what
it's Madness
yeah
so I want you to will you commit to
talking to somebody
yes I will
look into finding a counselor yeah
that's different than actually making
the call you promise you'll make a call
I'll make a call today do you promise
you'll go to the appointment
yes I promise you just promised in front
of all of America actually we only have
like 18 listeners but you just promised
in front of all of them
I'll do it I am in yeah
you are worth so much more
than being the relational janitor for
everybody in your life cleaning up
everybody else's messes
okay I agree yeah
I'm sorry sweetheart
no no butts it's just a lot
yeah no butts just and it's a lot and it
hurts right now and I'm sorry
thankfully
just the things you you have helped me
out
um I'm a big Harry Potter person and
you're like a Dumbledore to my Harry
Potter is that an old joke
is that an old joke no that's pretty old
I understand no oh you're not too far
off from me I'll take Dumbledore all day
long so I'm I'm grateful
um
you
are worth so much more you're worth
being well
please call somebody today this is going
to take some time to unravel this
because it's it's wired into you
and let's say this
um I don't know him I haven't talked to
him
I'd be happy to talk to your husband if
you want to call if he wants to call in
and maybe he's just hurting too and he
doesn't know how to do it and he just
said stupid things and put stupid things
on the table to try to make himself feel
better so I don't beat him up
too bad
it's as frustrating as that is
uh maybe he's hurting too
[Music]
all I have to say is you can't you can't
do anything about his nonsense other
than to say no and
go be the champion of your healing
let me know how it goes I'll walk with
you every step of the weekly
we'll be right back
good folks slowing down is a critical
aspect of mental health calming music
prayers meditation they're all great
ways to find peace and hallow makes it
easy to start a daily practice of
meditation hallow is the number one
Prayer app in the world and you can
tailor content towards your faith
tradition from scripture readings and
prayers to journaling Hollow makes it
easy to practice prayer meditate and
build a deeper more meaningful spiritual
life and ReDiscover true peace go to
hollow.com deloney today to get three
months of hollow for free
hello.com deloney
all right we're back let's go out to the
512 in Austin and talk to Lindsay hey
Lindsay what's up
hey Dr John how are you partying what
are you up to
not much
um I listened to your show like every
single day and I believe seriously I
always hear you um say to choose guilt
over resentment every time and my
question is what if I choose guilt over
resentment and then my spouse resents me
later for it
you can't control that
mm-hmm
and I hate that for you
what is your what is your spouse
presenting you over
um not yet but I'm like worried that it
will happen
you're pre-wiring about future potential
resentment
yes
I love it that's not anxious at all okay
so why are you pre-wiring about
potential future resentment
um okay I'll give you an example
um that we have so my husband and I come
from like really different backgrounds
culturally and
um we just we have a different family
Dynamics
so he would ideally like to see his
family a lot more than I would
um and you know I've offered like why
don't you go by yourself that type of
thing but it always turns out like he
wants me to come with we have a
one-year-old daughter and so he also
thinks it's like important for her to be
around his family and stuff like that
um
and so I've been really honest with him
like I'm not comfortable you know taking
as many trips down to see your family as
you would like to but you know we can
Compromise type of thing and we've been
working with a therapist and I will say
like he has been really good the last
time we went down there about
um changing the way the trip looks and
kind of catering to my needs more and
stuff like that but um I guess I'm just
worried that down the line like
obviously the inevitable will happen and
like family members will pass away and
like things like that and I just don't
want him to come back and say like we
should have spent more time with them
and it's your fault that we didn't
does he have a really overbearing mom
I would say they have he was definitely
raised by like an emotionally immature
mother yes okay
so when y'all go down to visit
do you get backseated
okay is that why you don't like to go or
is there other reasons
um unfortunately I didn't have a lot of
time to build a relationship with them
before like marriage and a baby so I do
feel like his family is like really
tight-knit and I'm kind of like the
outsider that's just like the black
sheep if you will is that a real thing
are you imagining that too
pretty real like
like kind of just like in the background
nobody really like talk to me or kind of
ask me like things about myself or makes
me feel included in the family
um it's really hard to get a word in
because they're all like really close
and
um so it just it just I'm really
uncomfortable there
I'm just trying to get to the level of
discomfort are you uncomfortable because
people aren't making overt efforts to
include you are you uncomfortable
because they're talking about awful
things or they're disgusting and rude or
they're grabby
see what I'm saying because here's the
thing if if you are unsafe
absolutely don't go never go
um I don't it's just awkward
I think it's more like I've tried to
even say like can your family come up
here because obviously it's really hard
to travel with we have like almost
one-year-old so it's not convenient to
do like a three hour road trip with a
baby
um and so like we've had instances where
like his mom will come here and she's
just like
I feel like she just makes comments that
are just like unnecessary you know of
course she does like she's emotionally
immature we've already established that
so it's like it's like it's like being
around a rattlesnake and you're like I
just feel like the rattlesnake just
makes noise
that's what they do that's what they do
people you know I understood understood
and you married him
yeah so you married them
now
you get to decide whether they hurt your
feelings or not
which sounds nutty
meaning his mom is going to be part of
his life unless she's abusive or she is
criminal or she is
insane right like whatever she's gonna
be part of his life you married into
that
and so
you get to decide what that boundary
looks like whether you're going to visit
or not visit whether you're going to be
around or whatever
but you're gonna be in each other's life
and so
when she pops off and makes all these
comments about I would never do it like
that and I don't do it like that and I
can't believe you keep your house like
this and I would be doing this and oh my
gosh that baby's gonna be so cold and
just just comments all the time
um
you get to decide whether you are
confident what you're doing
which if you have a nine or ten month
old you probably are not I didn't know
what day it was and
you get to decide whether she speaks
into your soul or not or whether she's
just this
Meandering piping old lady that is in
the house it's going to be over a couple
of times a year
you see what I'm saying like there's a
it's just a
the best way I can describe it it's like
have you ever been skiing like water
skiing
so when you first get the boat takes off
and you're sitting in the water it just
is a jet blast of water to your face
and then you Crest on top of it and you
get on top of the water and really
um if you're really good like my friend
Rachel Cruz we go skiing out
she gets in the water and will go skiing
and then get out of the water and her
hair is perfectly dry I don't even know
how she does that she's good at it and
so you can be around those people and
they aren't going to affect you like
right okay you can make all your
comments I don't care
now if you say something offensive
around my kid I'm gonna be I'm gonna I'm
gonna speak my mind if you say something
ugly about my my spouse or my husband or
my wife whatever I'm gonna speak up
but if you're just gonna pick at my
cooking and how clean my house is and
how you can't believe it whatever so
that's that's that's that's number one
number two
at some level your husband is choosing
to shoot himself in the foot and blame
you for it
right right if he doesn't want to go see
his family or I only want to go if it's
like this perfect picture I have in my
head
well then that's on him
I don't want you to spin to waste
valuable emotional and relational energy
worrying about things that might happen
five 10 or 15 years from now
I mean you're worrying about funerals
right
now let me diffuse like here's the
fastest way I've learned to defuse that
in my own life just say it out loud
I'm uncomfortable around your family and
when you don't go I'm worried that in 10
years if one if somebody passes away
You're Gonna blame me for the lack of
time you didn't spend with them
just say it out loud
yeah it's
I actually told him I was gonna be on
the call and and I told him my question
I said is there anything you want to add
to this or like you know put your two
cents in and he's like that's just a
really good question and I'm like okay
oh cause he is gonna be mad at you
someday no I don't
I don't either so sometimes I'm like he
grew up are you an emotionally abusive
mom of course these are people please
sir he had to be yeah but I'm like are
you compromising because like
you understand and this is like what you
also want to do or are you just doing it
to like get me to shut up
does it matter for you
yeah
because that that's asking a lot
I want you to do what I say and I want
you to want to do it the way I said it
because that's you see what I'm saying
yeah
if you say I don't want you to go or I
don't want us to go
and he says all right I won't go
you can't be mad at him for grieving
that
he gets that right because he had a
picture in his head that he was gonna
have one big happy family
and he doesn't
he has a fractured family
and that's not your fault
just is
but you can't get mad at him for not
feeling the same way you feel about a
thing
that's true is that fair so if he says
no I'm going to support my wife even
when it hurts
that's pretty awesome
now if he turns around and blames you
for it later that's pretty lame because
he's making he's making grown-up choices
here's the thing
a catchphrase like choose guilt over
resentment feel so good every time it
feels so good and it feels so neatly
wrapped up in a package and it's it's so
instructive I'm just gonna do this
instead of this
when the world gets chaotic I'm gonna do
this instead of this awesome
it also is really hard
and you can only choose your guilt and
if somebody chooses to resent you you
can't do anything about that unless you
want to go run be a people pleaser at
which point you're going to end up in a
cycle of resentment
so if somebody chooses to not be in
relationship with you it hurts grieve it
and you can get on about your day
and go figure out what happens next
I do want you to spend some time
personally
asking yourself
is the things that are happening when
you visit the family
are they cultural differences
are they Outsider differences or are
they purposely excluding you
because if it's cultural differences and
they're trying to honor you and the best
way they know to honor you is to not
offend you or not be weird around you so
they're just gonna try to Love You by
circling the wagons
then maybe you go learn some stuff about
this culture maybe you go take some
classes or learn some language whatever
the thing is I don't know what what the
culture is I don't even know anything
but maybe you make an effort to lean in
or if they're ugly people they just
don't want you around they're pissed off
at their their your husband for marrying
you and creating a family with you
then you've got to create an ALT
Universe you have to create another
world because they are opting out of
relationship with you
and their grandkid and their child
and that hurts man it's hard
but I'll tell you as a guy who spent a
big chunk of my adult life in anxious
mess
worrying and spinning up today about
things that may happen 5 10 15 20 years
from now is in a complete and utter
waste of your life don't do it
I lost years
of beautiful moments in the present
freaking out about things that may never
happen
and if they do okay I'll deal with them
when they happen
live your life now
continue to be honest with your husband
and remember your mother-in-law doesn't
get a vote you don't get a vote
and you get to decide what happens next
oh marriage is hard we'll be right back
[Music]
hey what's up now that my new book oh in
your past change your future is out in
the wild we've been hearing reviews and
feedback from readers and wow I'm so
grateful and one of the things I've been
most excited about hearing is that this
book is not just for people who are
healing from terrible traumatic
experience or other big scary things
from their past this book is for
everyone in every Walk of Life the
single 30 year old looking to sharpen
their mind the 25 year old hoping to
make new friends the parent who's tired
of seeing their kids eyes glued to a
screen but who doesn't know how to
re-enter their life people coming out of
abusive relationships everyone and this
book isn't me talking at you this book
is me walking with you because I've been
there too to better understand and
improve your mental relational and
emotional health please check out own
your past change your future at John
deloney.com today that's John
deloney.com today
all right we are back as we wrap up
today's show as we wrap up today's show
I am taking over
I'm hijacking the lyrics today what's up
of bread actually we're not going to do
lyrics today because I wanted to give
some people some information
so I follow us it's her birthday
everybody it's not it was two weeks ago
all right all right so I follow Sesame
Street on Instagram because we all need
a little Sesame Street as you're
scrolling social media
come on you need that but they've done
something that I thought was super cool
and a great resource for parents of
young kids so I wanted to make sure
everybody knew about it they've been
doing uh kicking off this past month an
Initiative for mental health and
emotional well-being of little kids
and it's multi-year multi-tiered
multi-platform so it's a big thing it's
got a ton of resources on it so if you
go to sesame.org Mental Health
there are videos there are worksheets
there are color sheets there's activity
guides there's all sorts of things that
you can go in and it talks about kids
and their feelings how to own their big
feelings I saw you coloring a picture at
your desk I know it was and now and I
felt better Elmo help me I'm pissed off
I'm gonna color a picture of Grover oh I
love Grover I know one of my favorite
books The Monster at the End of the book
a great great Grover book excellent
anywho but yeah so uh it's bilingual all
the resources are bilingual and you have
there's videos uh Elmo video called I
notice I feel I can I notice my emotions
how I feel and I can control it I think
adults should I participate as well
fantastic for some of you um there's
actually a um
a PSA campaign and there's a new podcast
episode with Dr Laurie Santos and the
happiness lab who's fantastic she's
awesome she's awesome she's doing a
whole podcast with Sesame Street and the
just the whole gist of it is to help
kids with their big emotions because
they just throw temper tantrums they
don't know what to do with all of their
emotions and there's a ton of resources
on the side I've put it in the show
notes already and I went through it and
I looked at it and man it would have
been great to have that stuff we're
coming up with Summer your kids are
going to be home and this isn't just for
three and four year olds this is for 30
and 40 years yeah I I'm a parent of
teenagers there's some stuff in here and
we can be using but it's just such a
great resource to teaching them about
their emotions now when they are three
four five six
and then later you have teenagers and
adults that can actually regulate them
how to turn the news off yeah and and
learn what their emotions mean that it's
okay to be angry like what got me was I
was flipping and social and it was Abby
Cadabby and a little thing that said I
feel grumpy today and I was like preach
sister I do too me too I know I tried to
I tried to get on the uh Sesame Street
as part of the thing and they said well
you've already got an Oscar the Grouch
on your show so we're gonna pass
I don't think they were talking about
Jenna see and this is where because I
know my emotions I could just let that
pass
and not say all the words that I want to
say hey when this season is over we're
all going to get
Sesame Street character tattoos I'm
buying
it's gonna be awesome
you're gonna make me get an Oscar the
crowd Target 100 yes I'll get a big bird
all right so that's Kelly
Kelly's
um insights of the days that we should
call them the kid sure Kelly's insights
of the day
Ben you can get some absurd music to go
with it Kelly's but hey take care of
your kids this summer as we approach
maybe a little of emotional and
um emotional well-being
some teaching about feelings and
emotions would be good for maybe all of
our country I think that'd be fantastic
all right that's it for today y'all stay
in school don't do drugs love y'all
[Music]